[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va voir
sa photo n'apparaît plus sur les murs
mais le fantôme de Saddam Hussein flotte
toujours ici
l'ex dictateur est d'abord et avant tout
un fils de la place un chef de clan un
membre de la famille pour son cousin
l'ancien colonel de l'armée irakienne le
verdict sur l'invasion américaine il y a
20 ans et sans appel
nous apporter la démocratie la liberté
mais au contraire ils ont détruit notre
pays dit-il ils ont détruit notre ville
nous n'avons plus rien pas même la loi
comme lui la plupart de ces hommes
étaient officier dans l'armée de Saddam
Hussein des membres du parti basse
aujourd'hui interdit
ils étaient des habitués des somptueux
palais du dirigeant ils sont encore
chefs de clans sunnite proche de Saddam
Hussein mais c'est une position
d'autorité qui n'a plus d'influence leur
privilège tout aussi anéanti que les
somptueux palais du dictateur
il se sentent relayés à un purgatoire
sans fin là
avoir un ministère au gouvernement pas
même un simple ministère
ils ne peuvent pas être directeurs
général dans les tailles irakiens ils ne
peuvent pas siéger au Parlement
nos fils souffre pour des raisons
politiques nous avons été marginalisés
tout le monde dans cette ville
le déferlement du groupe état islamique
n'a rien fait pour améliorer leur chance
de revenir dans les bonnes grâces de la
société beaucoup avaient soutenu
l'organisation terroriste
le chèque Rachid ne peut plus rentrer
chez lui dans le village d'allaja il y
possède une maison des terres mais comme
1500 familles qui habitaient l'endroit
qui a vu naître Saddam Hussein et qui a
accueilli sa dépouille en 2006 les
groupes armées chics qui contrôlentit
crit aujourd'hui lui en interdise
l'accès
sécuritaire dit-il je ne sais pas
pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas rentrer
chez nous est-ce que c'est simplement
parce que nous appartenons au clan de
Saddam Hussein
[Musique]
il ne leur reste que ces quelques photos
et le douloureux souvenir du jour où on
l'a appris leur fils il y a 7 ans
fazias se préparait à la prière du matin
quand des hommes armés et masqués ont
fait irruption dans la maison familiale
en criant le nom de leur fils
ne lui ont pas attaché les mains il ne
faisait que le frapper
après avoir roué de coups l'ensemble de
la famille ils sont repartis avec lui
sans explication
de fruits et de légumes ici au marché de
tikkrit comme son père avant lui un
jeune homme sans histoire assure ses
parents il n'entretenait aucun lien avec
l'État islamique ou des groupes
terroristes comme tous ceux qui ont pu
revenir vivre à le passage de le i il
lui avait fallu le prouver
commissariat de police on s'est contenté
de dire la famille qu'aucun service de
sécurité n'était venu arrêter rider
alors qu'ils ne les connaissent pas ils
étaient plusieurs à venir dans notre
maison ils ne sont pas sortis de nulle
part on ne sait pas mais je pense que ce
sont les mêmes forces qui contrôlent le
secteur
les forces dont elles parlent sans
jamais vraiment oser les nommer ce sont
les unités de mobilisation populaire des
groupes paramilitaires formés pour
combattre le groupe état islamique à
l'appel de l'ayatollah cistanie
ils sont restés en contrôle de ces
critiques et ses environs après les
combats aujourd'hui ce sont eux qui font
la loi dit la famille Ryder
c'est un état dans l'état dit-il tous
les éléments du gouvernement se
conduisent comme s'ils étaient eux-mêmes
un état dans l'état la police les
employés municipaux même les simples
employés tout le monde se comporte comme
l'état
on a demandé à parler aux trois
principaux groupes armés qui contrôlent
toujours titre et ses environs mais
malgré nos demandes insistantes et
répétées tous ont refusé de nous parler
en Irak il y a les voix officielles pour
faire avancer les choses et les autres
canons ceux de l'ombre les petites et
les grandes corruptions restent une
maladie incurable qui afflige les
Irakiens
[Musique]
l'ont bien compris il y a un an un homme
est venu leur montrer une photo de rider
il était vieilli mais c'était bien lui
envie l'homme leur a demandé 3000
dollars américains pour leur rendre leur
fils
je lui dis que 3000 dollars c'était
beaucoup pour une simple photo que je
devais le voir il a refusé mais je jure
je n'ai pas cet argent
lui il nostalgie de Saddam Hussein à
cette époque au moins il y avait une
sorte de pacte d'unité nationale fondée
sur un point commun
[Musique]
tout le monde avait peur de Saddam
Hussein après l'invasion américaine les
choses n'étaient pas plus mal dit-il
même si des soldats lui ont tiré dans la
jambe
les Américains ont arrêté 4 fois mais
après ils m'ont relâché ils se sont
excusés
notre vie maintenant est misérable et
triste nous sommes opprimés ça nous rend
malade quand on sort dans la rue ce ne
sont que des mauvaises nouvelles ce
n'était pas comme ça avant honnêtement
les étrangers doivent revenir finir le
travail autrement il n'y a pas d'avenir
pour l'Irak ou de la dire ruine qu'ils
ont laissé derrière